um well we just had a song about
reuniting so who are you excited to
reunite with during the pandemic because
we couldn't see anyone i know i think
that's so nice what you guys did um
i want to reunite with you in las vegas
while you're on stage
i want to come up and hug you until
security tells me to leave um
but
genuinely i'm i'm excited about
reuniting with
the the actual um
you know experience of live performance
i'm really excited about that me too i
literally i already planned two concerts
because people are starting to announce
like dates and i'm like i want to see
george straight celine dion just said
she's coming back to vegas i'm just i
just wanted to i just i just want to see
shows i'm not even i know yes i want to
do shows but i feel like i've been able
to at least sing this whole time i so
miss like being entertained in that
sense and the energy of it and singing
songs with strangers you don't know it's
awesome i know and i also really miss
dancing i love to dance
i'm i'm a big birthday is coming up for
me and i'm i'm really looking forward to
just trying to do a lot of dancing
across the country across the country no
you have a huge birthday coming up it's
it's 50 right yep 50 is coming up that's
amazing
so awesome and um
you know what's so great about turning
any age is that all your other friends
are turning that age too
and i know that that sounds silly but
you know your peers grow up with you
like everybody does day 25 so that's
what's so fun so i'm very very lucky to
have such great friends so i'm really
looking forward to doing something fun
that's going to involve a lot of dancing
i think and involve people you're lucky
when you have a lot of us had our
birthdays in the pandemic like so you
know there wasn't generally do anything
so that that's awesome especially for a
50th but you know what the trick is to
um to aging is just always have older
friends because you're always the young
one
the only idea yeah
and they're like hey
[Music]